you
all righty D for Best Buy test is that
what it is
okay so Queen's Gambit line
all right I'm jumping out of the main
hall here I'm out of the main hall
all right Queen's Gambit it is tirage
okay
well this could turn into a pan off Bob
Minich an isolated Queen pon position
yeah I don't want to move my bishop so
fast either okay I guess we're gonna
have that here comes B five I think he
belongs on d3 so let's keep him there
because he has aggressive intentions
that's why he's gonna stick around there
there's white gonna try to win upon
--tags --tags --tags wouldn't be too
good because I'm on the rook hmm I think
the Queen belongs here facilitating this
advance now my my one concern is where
does this rook belong let me go here
can't be too comfortable to be opposite
that Queen let's try this
so this is five-o here five-o I almost
want to all I voluntarily retreat my
bishop yeah let me do that um I might
want to be I'm thinking about capturing
on c5 and then playing b4 maybe I mean I
could do this but that's a pain I think
oh let's see well what other candidate
moves what I want to consider I'm not
really sure hmm efore takes our the my
two main ones I can't this has enough
protection d5 let's just go with this I
gotta make a move
I can't think too long here and my idea
was to play this but you know I could do
this move right now maybe this is the
right idea I have enough coverage for
this and now I don't have to worry about
b4 kicking my knife from this square I
think this is the right idea so at least
I bring into question the stability of
this f6 Knight maybe this could be
annoying Bishop e3 placing the knight in
the pin threatening b4 so I'm just one
move away so this is good for multiple
reasons right clears the way for the
Bishop prepares to fully develop maybe
it looks to kick the knight on f6 with
d5 I probably should just go here right
now vision of III the Knights in a pin
can't be too excited about that
so where's the Queen gonna go where's
her next best place to be now bear in
mind I'm struck I'm masking my Queens
view of this square okay there she goes
there she goes I could go hang on
I could go here but after rook takes
rook takes then I think maybe you could
successfully capture on this square
what about Bishop d4 I'm gonna go at
that I'm not really a great fan of doing
this type of move just kind of putting
the bishop out there in the line of fire
but it has enough support my queen is
now there to protect me for for a third
time and maybe next I want to play rook
c1 with ideas of b4 and then an eventual
discovery against the Queen on c7 we're
dead even on time okay let's see I'm
looking to maybe have something against
the black ink position with this move
available I could maybe be having
something against this square I guess
the Queen here is being there's an idea
with this move but what about kicking
the knight right now I think I actually
like that let's go with that now there's
some loose pieces over here on c3 but I
think they could be remedied or they
could be defended now what about pawn
push pawn push there's bishop takes nine
I don't know that I really like that
let's get my rook working okay whew that
was played very quickly very quickly all
right so there's a lot of pressure being
placed on e4
what about pawn push
I'm gonna try it my pawn structure could
turn out to be very ugly very soon or
maybe not Bishop takes I take here you
know where's this Knight gonna go maybe
I get maybe it's okay to have double
deaf pawns but if Knight d5 and right
away I think I'm gonna play Knight here
and if Knight f4 I could play Queen III
I'm not sure exactly what it's amounting
to but again as soon as he leaves
h7 is a soft point so I could
immediately think about like Queens III
stuff so we are going with this and I'm
losing my throat sorry about that
so pawn or queen huh you know what I'm
gonna go with the Queen not just because
I like Queen trades but I want to be
able to change the structure if the
knight goes here I want to be able to
take and saddle black with an isolated
pawn if that wants to be if that's gonna
be avoided the knight has to go back or
go here maybe that's not so bad of a
square h5 Bishop here seems very
appealing
hmm
maybe I should have kept the Queen's on
too late now right too late now buddy
too late it's way too late oh you know
what hang on those bishops are deadly
very deadly rook here bishop here
hang on rook be is needed maybe uh Oh is
black sweating now is black getting
nervous is black safe and sound or is
black tactically vulnerable maybe
alright so black is going with this
we're gonna see we are definitely gonna
see our Bishop here the rook is attacked
the pawn is attacked I'm just gonna go
with it why you know that I'm not seeing
what the problem is with that the other
thing I like about it is that when this
pawn follows b5 is ready to follow soon
thereafter right so the rook is hit but
this Bishop is hit I could grab this
though I also have a flight square let's
just go with it time is ticking away
I could also grab here and defend what
am I missing
I don't think I'm missing anything I
think my opponent was missing that my
night is still defended after rook takes
I could take here he's still defended
unless the follow up f6 was the idea but
I could play here so I think that was a
miscalculation as we started to approach
let's do that as we started to approach
less time here maybe there's still way I
could be losing some material but not
seeing it this must be working out rook
back here I could hit him one hit black
with another fork Bishop d7 yeah let's
go with this I want to pick up this pawn
with check if I do this in immediately
there's e5 and then I'm then I'm
successfully kicked from the defense of
this square so let's take here with
check
and now finally well its let's just go
here and offer some exchanges hang on I
like this move better I think this is
cleaner just to get rid of the pesky
knight the bishop guards f3 so I just
want to get rid of him
the Knights gone then I don't have very
many worries save this guy so I'm still
just up a minor piece and I want to make
sure everything is nice and cozy
everything's defended 39 seconds and I'd
like to get my pawn up right here just
to keep my bishop very stable just so
I'll have to worry about g6 h5 and
everything is now tucked in you know I
could enter I mean I could have entered
a while back but my bishops in a really
strong spot and where's the knockout
where is that knockout here take care
with Czech bishops on the rook and just
anything they're you know just less than
a second okay we had resignation all
right let's go back good game let's
let's go back for a quick second or two
they're saying thank you
GG all right what did we have okay we
had a tirage and there's always that
patience factor that comes in out of
this opening with not wanting to move
the bishop or not wanting to capture on
the c4 c5 squares until the
corresponding king bishops move but
black goes in for it right away so I'm
able to capture in one shot on c4 but
the idea behind it is to follow up like
so b5 so black gets that in and I think
these are pretty common moves in Queen
e2 the Knights being connected the Queen
coming out here I'm not sure where
I think the this is where I start to
wonder if there's an improvement on my
end or even on blacks end I mean I did
this because I did this move because I
wanted to take here and not have to deal
with the night recapturing with tempo so
that's why I came back voluntarily and
now I took and then I played efore you
see here's that here's the other thing
to bear in mind it's that it's that what
oh it's that if I'm to take right away
the night gains a tempo on my bishop and
when it comes back to c2 then black gets
to throw the knight on to this efore
square and I could forget about trying
to get an e for and if I'm not getting
an e for then my bishop starts to have
an issue so I that's this this move is
actually played and not just to avoid
the recapture with tempo but it's to
make sure I could finish my development
Bishop C to castles was there even
something better I can give my knight a
kick but I always have this tempo
gaining move on the Queen that could be
a bit awkward but okay castles Knight
here I get an e4 before a piece is
planted on that square now we get we're
both fully developed the Knights in the
pin black gets out of it right away
this was an awkward move for me to make
but maybe it is maybe it is alright
Bishop d4 I'm not sure this is a very
tense middle game here mmm doesn't seem
so bad bishop they're right idea of
piling up or I don't know a right idea
but it's it's clear that trying to put
some more pressure on e4 with Queen b7
stuff the five Knight back right here
maybe yeah I guess maybe the decision to
take the night isn't best maybe maybe
just jump right into this square
I'm sure that's what my opponent was
also thinking about 95 and to be honest
I'm not sure if I'm not sure what is
better this can't be I don't know that
this could be so bad I have the bishop
here but a damaged structure and I
really started to worry a bit about the
night getting into f4 so I gave the rook
a kick and maybe rook c8 is where it
starts to crumble the follow-up move as
was played in the game with taking here
is just not working out as I am
defending you know after this he's a
he's not really threatening to win the
night so I think the accurate move after
Bishop here is rook to b8 rook to b8 and
then then I'm not sure maybe that's the
improvement it's the most natural move
to go to an open file but maybe rook b8
first I wonder if there was some worry
of this and the rooks getting trapped
the difference after if I follow up if
rip be a DIF then follow up with Bishop
a7 rook here and now if I do this now
I'm in some trouble I'm not easily just
winning the a6 pawn losing a piece
pretty sure oops okay so it just got a
little bit screwy there this was pretty
much the end though I think rook to b8
was the improvement in this this tense
game actually out of the tirage defense
alright GG safe and sound
you